speak of control yet you caught chaos
this is mo isn't it now what are we a
team no no no we're a chemical mixture
that makes chaos we're we're a time bomb
you need to step away well I shouldn't
the guy let off a little steam you know
damn well why back off oh I'm starting
to want you to make me ya big man and a
suit of armor
take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist I
know guys with none of that worth 10 of
you I've seen the footage the only thing
you really fight for is yourself you're
not the guy to make the sacrifice play
to lay down on a wire or let the other
guy crawl over you I think I would just
cut the wire
always a way out you know you may not be
a threat but you better stop pretending
to be a hero a hero like you your
laboratory experiment Rogers everything
special about you bottle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
put on the suit let's go a few rounds
you people are so Petty and tiny yes
agent Romanoff would you escort dr.
banner back to his where you rented my
room the cell was just in case you
needed to kill me but you can't I know I
tried I got low and then seemed in so I
put a bullet in my mouth and the other
guys spit it out so I moved on I focused
on helping other people I was good until
you dragged me back into this freak show
and put everyone here at risk you want
to know my secret agent Romanoff you
want to know how I stay calm you're
better
but down the center
you
you